did you know there's a real person out
there in England putting on a mask in
stopping muggings and assaults in the
dead of night he dresses in a black
bandana mask a tight black shirt and
military pants
he knows martial arts and can fight
multiple people once and he stays in a
single neighborhood within a major city
doesn't he sound just like the real-life
Batman ha I bet he's pissed actually he
sent an anonymous email claiming he
wants to be referred to as the shadow
like the pulp hero from his childhood
isn't it funny how something completely
different gets looked at by the media
and they always go you know what that
needs to be Batman oh wait that happened
with every single thing DC is produced
since I don't know 2008 ish am I the
only one who's getting kind of sick of
Batman every character from DC has to
bite off of the same formula DC used to
have much more variety than this but the
way things are looking for the DC
Cinematic Universe the title of each
movie should be Batman vs. Comedy dawn
of the know colors anyone missed the
days of here's the rest of the Justice
League
Batman's over there being Moody and they
all make fun of him for it everyone had
a unique personality and their own
methods of being superheroes they didn't
all conform to the same sense of ethics
as him and he certainly wasn't the
leader he was just the team bad boy that
was cool because he was different
laughing
what about you Batman I'm not really a
people person but when you need help and
you will call understood the dynamic
doesn't work if they're all whiney sad
kids it started in the comics and it
slowly enveloped all the mediums that DC
material exists in in short Batman
ruined DC on the screen number one all
DC movies are conforming into the Batman
Cinematic Universe whether he's in the
movie or not you can feel the Dark
Knight's tone and cinematography and
everything now The Dark Knight did a lot
for superhero movies as a genre by being
cerebral and thought provoking and
taking itself seriously which in turn
helped people take the genre seriously
it played a major role in the fad we
have going now where all the big
blockbusters star characters and tights
but they feel this need to copy that
formula everywhere Man of Steel being
the leading example of the moment when
people think of Superman you imagine
seeing characters look off into the
horizon as the apocalypse slowly
consumes the world how about someone
being dragged into a pile of skulls
while someone else sits there and talks
about how hard he gets thinking of
planetary genocide an entire city being
blown up repeatedly by a laser slamming
down into the ground from the sky
breaking someone's neck and crying over
their corpse it's all signs that Warner
Brothers felt like they had to make
Superman more of an adult-oriented
property this ain't no family-friendly
movie kids I'll tell you that much take
your dinosaurs and go elsewhere it seems
to be part of this committee thinking
that if something Dark Knight sells well
make everything else like it to keep the
same group interested in guarantee
financial security
so boring business [ __ ] aside Man of
Steel pissed off a good portion of
people by being too violent and dark I
personally think it's my favorite
arthouse black and white independent
film what we can take away is that DC
thinks David s Goyer is a genius it
needs to be emulated in everything
because of his one fluke with the Dark
Knight
Superman is now depressing in sepia tone
with a plot about a character learning
that he is so symbol and using his
resources to stop a bad guy who is
insane and anarchistic for the sake of
being insane and anarchistic Zod doesn't
want to save his race any more than
joker wanted to save that pen he was a
crazed
murus evil psychopath and Superman can't
crack a joke to save his life there was
one joke in the movie about how Louis
got cut off before she could say
Superman are you laughing yet everyone
speaking of what about the title Man of
Steel instead of using the superheros
name we got to use his tagline as the
title just like that one thing following
that line of logic the Green Arrow movie
should be called the Emerald Archer or
the flash should be called the fastest
man alive which sounds like the title of
a sad independent comedy about an office
worker with a terrible bedroom life and
a heart of gold despite everything the
next Superman movie is about Batman the
long and boring title says it all
it's clear where their priorities lie
the next movie in their lineup is
Suicide Squad a film about several
supervillains being recruited from
prison by the government to do
impossible missions and reduce their
prison sentences that actually sounds
like DC's guardians of the galaxy
something weird and off-the-wall to keep
the universe fresh and introduce a ton
of obscure characters the mainstream it
could be really cool let's look at the
lineup shall we
ah do I need to say any more away yeah I
do Batman is in the movie too they
couldn't just let their flagship
characters stay out of something for
five minutes it's like if Marvel had
spider-man in every movie from the first
phase of their series it wouldn't allow
for any creativity and he just
overshadow everyone he was put in a room
with they had one movie without Batman
and I think the only reason he wasn't
there is because they couldn't figure
out a way to shoehorn him in at least it
can be interesting to see Batman and
Superman interacting on screen for the
first time but that's all that movie has
gone for hey remember when they
announced this story and Marvel went the
oh [ __ ] what do we do to save Captain
America 3 it's gonna get destroyed at
the box-office by anything with Batman
in it I just turn it into a full-on
Avengers movie with a misleading title
that'll help you guys so yeah Batman's
presence is affecting everything and not
just in cinema 4d see number 2
Batman is taking over the television
most of us will sleep better knowing
that Superman is watching over us anyone
still remember that show arrow yeah me
neither
but it was a big step in the right
direction for superhero TV shows which
prior to it we're all just uh little
well it had a pretty unique feel an
identity it was a show about a vigilante
using his skills to actually kill
high-ranking ruffians as part of a
revenge quest stopping street crimes and
bank robberies did happen on occasion
but it was more of an afterthought
Oliver Queen also had a pretty large
group of friends and family to keep up
with and wasn't the depressed loner type
it had a pretty good first season but
then the hype for Dark Knight Rises blew
up just before the series premiered and
it seems like some executives said we
need to make it more like Batman now all
of his friends a family died off slowly
or become weird vigilantes too he
decides he's not allowed to kill
villains anymore and he gets a stick up
his nock about becoming a symbol and I
have to stand for something more he
fought a couple of obscure dropouts from
Batman's rogues gallery before but the
entirety of season 3 was about fighting
the same guy from Batman Begins this
Batman wannabe used to have depth but
now he's just got nothing left in the
old quiver
you know arrow had a season and a half
to be good but some others were dead on
arrival I present to you Gotham the
Batman show that didn't have the budget
to have Batman in it not only does it
screw up every known timeline for that
character but it has little Bruce Wayne
drawing pictures of skulls and listening
to heavy metal in the background of
boring episode after boring episode it's
the most unnecessary TV show I've ever
seen it has a relation to Batman so they
naturally thought it would draw loads of
money and be an instant hit right yet
they do absolutely nothing to expand on
these iconic characters it just shows
them walking around doing menial tasks
and being common cops and robbers 20
years before they do anything actually
interesting now don't mistake my hatred
of these shows and movies for being dark
and gritty crime dramas that isn't the
problem at all dark and gritty stuff can
be great it's the fact that they are so
pathetically reliant on a guy in a bat
costume that they can't have their own
identity they're just echoes of the
movie they might as well be
advertisements for the [ __ ] movie as
much as the daytime soap opera BS and
weird casting bugs
I applaud the flash TV show for at least
trying to do its own thing without the
stains of broody Magatha rage all over
it and a dark and gritty superhero show
can be done well look at daredevil I
think it works so well as in addition to
the Marvel Universe because it is so
different from everything else there is
a level of variety from those bright and
action-packed comedy films about the
Avengers so I guess in a roundabout sort
of way what I'm trying to say is number
three what I'm trying to say is bats is
an interesting character he always has
been actually never mind he wasn't
interesting until Frank Miller but I
digress he's one of the most deep and
thought-provoking heroes of the DC
Universe and he feels like the most
down-to-earth and realistic here on
their roster people need dramatic
examples to shake them out of apathy and
I can't do that as Posh Wayne as a man
I'm flesh and blood I can be ignored I
can be destroyed but as a symbol
but a symbol I can be incorruptible
I can be everlasting what's it something
mental something terrifying but he can't
be the center of attention he can't be
everything the thing about having a
whole universe of characters and
locations and ideas is that well they
don't have to all be attached to the
same story they don't have to all be
exactly the same
Superman's personality and his costume
are allowed to be colorful and he can
fight people who aren't just insane
terrorists Wonder Woman can be a tough
female hero kicking ass just as well as
any of the other guys without having to
get her start in a Batman movie she
deserves more than to be just a cameo in
an ornament for Batman vs Superman to
flaunt around in the trailer Aquaman can
have a fun personality in a self-aware
writing style to offset how [ __ ]
boring Aquaman is Batman can have his
own movie about doing what he does best
mope on a rooftop about how hard it is
being a handsome physically fit
billionaire who can operate outside the
law my life is too hood you guys
everyone should pay attention to me the
formula of just be Batman only get DC so
far right up until they get to a movie
about the flash that character is
impossible to make dark and gritty and
depressing when the time comes for them
to come out of their comfort zone they
won't have any idea how to do it and the
project will fall apart just like the
other time they did the exact same thing
it's time to get someone in charge of
the DC Cu name does
look at a hall so that they could ensure
that each director doesn't run away with
the ideas and do all the dumb things I
just said they were doing I have high
hopes that a movie like Shazam will be a
big hit with audiences maybe teach DC
that they are allowed to have fun and
break out of the formulaic pattern but
you never know it could just as easily
turn into a mess then why do you want to
kill me I don't want to kill you what
would I do without you no no you you
complete me you're garbage